is this like date night without baby are
y'all like how happy are you right now
he's the best yeah how exciting and how
does it change your life having that
child everything everything has changed
but I think the most amazing thing for
both of us is like having him has really
I don't know what's the word I'm looking
for has like amped us up I guess for all
the choices that we make it's all her
for when he can do whatever he wants yes
he's ready to do it so a lot of the
choices we make her for that now instead
of like oh this sounds cool because you
know I want to do it we say we look for
investments like everything is like okay
we want him to have what we didn't have
growing up
I had to get on Twitter the other day
because I saw where people were getting
on you about that picture and I said no
no I said I had to get on and say yo
these two are in love love like that
silly stupid love go back and look
through their Instagram feed I was like
I know what it is I'm not tripping over
Marina night
thank you end of end of it we know what
it is to stop
[Music]